[білоруською] У нас у магазинах зовсім пропав мир.
[білоруською] Спершу вищого сорту, а потім і той,
найгірший, яким перебивалися десятиліттям.
[білоруською] Лікарні переповнені.
Є уже й перші жертви.
[білоруською] Деякі ще доживають
на старих запасах, але вони швидко закінчаться.
[білоруською] Більшість перейшла на гнів.
[білоруською] Ще вчора як екзотична страва –
він тепер безкоштовний на кожному кроці.
[білоруською] Люди пригощають одне одного,
щедро заправляючи надією.
[білоруською] Протестний рух почався не тільки
з того, що люди почали виходити на вулицю,
[білоруською] а й з того, що вони
почали проявляти свій креатив.
[білоруською] Білоруси раніше, напевно, себе так сильно
не відчували білорусами, як вони відчули себе 2020 року.
[білоруською] Це дуже істотний момент,
який загалом будує,
[білоруською] по-перше, всі протестні дії зараз, і,
[білоруською]  по-друге, який дуже впливає,
безумовно, на майбутню Білорусь,
[білоруською] яка будуватиметься вже після зміни режиму.
[білоруською] Будь-яка революція — травматична.
[білоруською] Особливо коли ми маємо загальну історію
і розуміємо, звідки це все витікає.
[білоруською] І ми рухаємось, я сподіваюсь,
в одному напрямку.
[білоруською] Українці, звісно, підтримують.
[білоруською] Досить часто питали, що можна зробити,
можливо якась фінансова допомога потрібна
[білоруською] або речі, або їжа, підвезти щось,
зустріти когось, надати притулок на певний час.
[білоруською] Українці дуже привітно ставляться
до білорусів, які сюди зараз приїжджають.
[білоруською] 2020 року не відбулось нічого такого
(я маю на увазі вибори), чого не відбувалося раніше,
[білоруською] що не повинно було обурювати
людей раніше так, як це обурило їх зараз.
[білоруською] Але тут спрацювали ще додаткові триґери.
[білоруською] Ми знаємо, що 2020 року
почалася всесвітня пандемія,
[білоруською] з’явився коронавірус,
який Лукашенко заперечував,
[білоруською] який не хотів визнавати в країні.
[білоруською] І коли почалися масові захворювання людей,
[білоруською] коли сотні людей потрапили в лікарні,
коли в лікарів не було спеціального обладнання,
[білоруською] не було медичної апаратури
або простих масок.
[білоруською] Тоді з’явилися потужні волонтерські рухи,
тоді вже всім стало зрозуміло, що держава нікого не буде захищати.
[білоруською] Держава буде робити все,
щоб захистити себе, щоб Лукашенко зберіг владу.
[білоруською] І, звісно, це переломило в певному сенсі
розуміння ситуації в головах багатьох людей.
[білоруською] І ось так збіглося, що воно все відбулося перед виборами,
перед президентською кампанією і плавно перетекло в неї.
[білоруською] І ми побачили, що вийшли нові обличчя,
нарешті з’явилися нові люди, які претендували на крісло президента.
[білоруською] Зрозуміло, що остаточні числа
ніколи не буде відомо напевно.
[білоруською] Але ми бачили, що багато
на яких ділянках перемагала Тихановська.
[білоруською] І люди зрозуміли,
що щось змінилось. І це не…
[білоруською] Раніше всі думали, що напевно все ж 50%
голосує за Лукашенка, може не 80, але більшість.
[білоруською] Але зараз все було не так.
[білоруською] Тому коли всі зрозуміли, що більшість,
насправді, не за нього, люди пішли разом на вулиці.
[білоруською] Ось так і відбувся
цей перелом в історії Білорусі.
[білоруською] На вулицю вийшли не тільки ОМОНівці,
не тільки міліція, але й армія.
[білоруською] Проти звичайних людей,
в яких не було ніякої зброї.
[білоруською] Людей почали бити,
людей почали катувати.
[білоруською] Вони почали тікати і в Україну,
і в Польщу, і в Литву, і в деякі інші країни також.
[білоруською] І в Росію, на жаль, безумовно,
тому що там не було безпечно і не є зараз.
[білоруською] Ми знаємо, що російські
служби видають білорусів.
[білоруською] І ось нещодавно це також сталося.
[білоруською] Затримали ще одну людину,
а потім знайшли уже в Білорусі.
[білоруською] До України я багато де мандрувала і жила.
[білоруською] Я певний час навчалась у Штатах, у Норвегії.
[білоруською] Почався цей міцний рух відродження
громадського сектору в Україні після 2014 року.
[білоруською] З’явилось багато різних
цікавих правозахисних ініціатив.
[білоруською] Тому так і вийшло,
що я переїхала до України
[білоруською] і ніколи про це не шкодувала,
тому що це був і є чудовий досвід.
[білоруською] Всі ці відповідні знання, які ми збирали
останні п’ять-шість років з моїми колегами,
[білоруською] саме тут, в Україні, застосовуємо
для того, щоб допомогти білорусам.
[білоруською] Ми не просто ініціатива,
яка працює в Києві.
[білоруською] Ми можемо допомагати, по суті, по всій країні,
консультувати також людей, які в інших містах перебувають.
[білоруською] Дуже важливий момент –
це допомога біженцям.
[білоруською] Ті, хто приїжджає сюди,
хто вимушений був залишити країну,
[білоруською] тому що вдома проти них відкрите
кримінальне переслідування.
[білоруською] Вдома їх можуть позбавити батьківських прав.
[білоруською] Вдома їх відраховують
з університетів і призивають в армію.
[білоруською] І вдома просто небезпечно.
[білоруською] Ми зараз перебуваємо у Free Belarus Center –
це ініціатива, яка була створена в серпні 2020 року.
[білоруською] І зараз у нас,
крім психологічно-юридичної допомоги,
[білоруською] є ще допомога з житлом,
продуктами харчування, одягом.
[білоруською] Є невелика стипендіальна програма.
[білоруською] І намагаємося також ще й вести комунікацію
з українськими державними органами для того,
[білоруською] щоб покращити ситуацію для білорусів,
які змушені зараз сюди приїжджати.
[білоруською] Тут у нас невеликий куточок
гуманітарної допомоги.
[білоруською] До нас приїжджають речі з різних країн.
[білоруською] Тут одяг переважно.
Одяг чоловічий, жіночий і дитячий.
[білоруською] Останнім часом багато людей
приїжджають з дітьми.
[білоруською] І ось у нас зараз,
до речі, є одна нерозпакована.
[білоруською] Ми можемо подивитись,
що там усередині.
[білоруською] Я не знаю. Буде сюрприз для всіх.
[білоруською] Справа в тому, що люди дізнаються
про свою небезпеку в останній момент.
[білоруською] У них, насправді, уже немає часу
для того, аби підготуватися до відִ’їзду.
[білоруською] Вони просто хапають наплічник,
беруть своїх близьких, дітей.
[білоруською] Їдуть на кордон або купують квиток
на літак і вилітають з тим, що було.
[білоруською] І, звісно ж, коли в тебе
практично нічого з собою немає,
[білоруською] то простіше за все звернутись
до такої організації, як, наприклад, наша.
[білоруською] І ми тоді зможемо допомогти.
[білоруською] Потім вони вже влаштовуються.
[білоруською] Вони шукають собі роботу
і уже більш-менш влаштовується все.
[білоруською] Так, що у нас тут?
Тут, напевно, також дитячі речі.
[білоруською] Так.
[білоруською] Для маленьких дітей,
зовсім маленьких до того ж. Ну й часто такі є.
[білоруською] У нас була мама,
яка була змушена тікати.
[білоруською] Її попередній чоловік був міліціонером.
[білоруською] І коли він дізнався, що вона активно
долучається до протестів, протестного руху,
[білоруською] він почав їй погрожувати тим,
що її позбавлять батьківських прав.
[білоруською] І тому вона була змушена швидко їхати.
Ось у неї троє дітей.
[білоруською] Ще в серпні ми практично
одразу повісили біло-червоно-білий прапор.
[білоруською] І цікаво було потім спостерігати, як на вулиці
почали з’являтись інші такі ж прапори і також українські.
[білоруською] І вулиця стала строкатою.
І воно виглядало, немов перекличка.
[білоруською] Біло-червоно-білий прапор
насправді ж був нашим національним.
[білоруською] А все почалося 1918 року.
[білоруською] Його обрала рада БНР, і після,
у Радянському Союзі, звісно ж, це все змінилось.
[білоруською] Ми знаємо, що з’явилися
радянські прапори у всіх радянських країнах.
[білоруською] Потім, 1991 року, коли країна стала незалежною,
ми повернулись до нашого символу, білоруської мови також.
[білоруською] Але, на жаль, Лукашенко змінив усе назад,
і відкотив до символів, які були в Радянському Союзі.
[білоруською] І раніше за біло-червоно-білий прапор могли,
звісно, і затримати, і конфіскувати його,
[білоруською] при тому, що раніше він не був заборонений.
[білоруською] Але зараз вони намагаються,
звісно, різними шляхами зробити так,
[білоруською] щоб люди не виказували свою солідарність.
[білоруською] 23 травня 2021 року Роман Протасевич –
[білоруською] людина, яка в минулому була
одним з адміністраторів телеграм-каналу NEXTA,
[білоруською] яка вела основну стрічку новин під час
серпневих протестів в Білорусі, був затриманий.
[білоруською] І не те, що затриманий.
[білоруською] Літак, на якому він летів з Афін до Вільнюса,
посадили. До того ж посадили примусово.
[білоруською] Нинішня влада Білорусі
вдалася до безпрецедентних заходів.
[білоруською] Вони підняли в повітря
білоруський військовий винищувач.
[білоруською] І змусили пілотів пасажирського літака
сісти в Мінську, змінити, по суті, траєкторію польоту.
[білоруською] І все це відбулося тільки для того,
щоб затримати молодого хлопця 20 з лишком років.
[білоруською] І, щоб ув’язнити його, по суті,
в тюрмі, зробити його заручником.
[білоруською] Це, звісно, була дія, якої, напевно, ще ніхто ніколи
не бачив в історії не те, що Білорусі, але й усієї Європи.
[білоруською] І Євросоюз назвав ці події, по суті,
актом тероризму (дехто використовував це слово),
[білоруською] але більшість все ж таки схиляється до того,
що це був акт повітряного піратства.
[білоруською] Можна, звісно, читати новини, можна читати
деякі зведення, можна читати телеграм-канали.
[білоруською] Але там все відбувається
крок за кроком, і воно все літеральне.
[білоруською] Мистецтво дозволяє все ж таки побачити
інші сенси, докласти свій зміст в те, що ілюструє митець.
[білоруською] З’явилась така ось ідея,
що можна об’єднати кілька різних заходів в один.
[білоруською] І більше того, зробити це
ще й на майданчику Києво-Могилянської академії.
[білоруською] Місце, яке відоме своєю відмінною,
по-перше, освітою, по-друге, волелюбним духом.
[білоруською] І білоруси, які приходять на події,
присвячені Білорусі,
[білоруською] відчувають, що вони не покинуті,
[білоруською] що, по-перше, вони можуть
насправді знову об’єднатись,
[білоруською] незважаючи на те,
що вони уже не в Білорусі,
[білоруською] вони можуть щось разом робити,
і це їх підтримує морально і культурно.
[білоруською] Це чудова можливість і познайомитись,
бо багато людей приїжджає, нікого тут не знаючи.
[білоруською] І потім, коли вони зустрічаються
на білоруських імпрезах,
[білоруською] вони знаходять таких самих однодумців,
[білоруською] які можливо раніше приїхали сюди,
трохи краще влаштувались.
[білоруською] І в них, по-перше, будуються нові соціальні
зв’язки, вони починають одне одному тут допомагати.
[білоруською] Ворог мій, надія моя,
бачив щоночі смерть твою, засинаючи в тилу.
[білоруською] Двері мого дому завжди відкриті, завжди раді
перекинутись кількома приємними словами під пляшку цикути.
[білоруською] І його дух радості цієї розмови.
[білоруською] 90% моїх друзів і знайомих –
це або поети, або прозаїки, або перекладачі.
[білоруською] Я трішки перекладав з української.
[білоруською] У нас є сайт «ЛітРАЖ»,
то ми на ньому викладаємо переклади.
[білоруською] По-перше, щоб було цікаво плюс познайомити
білоруських читачів з новою молодою українською поезією.
[білоруською] Ну й не тільки молодою.
[білоруською] Ми ховали рідних, друзів,
живих класиків, лідерів нації,
[білоруською] керівників сумнівних організацій,
хом’яка під під’їздом,
[білоруською] собаку на узліссі,
муху в тарілці, а дехто і Бога в серці.
[білоруською] Але президент у труні – такого в себе
ми ще не бачили, такого досвіду нам не вистачало.
[білоруською] Та я вважаю, що коли ти живеш у певній країні,
то природно, що ти повинен ну хай не розмовляти, але розуміти.
[білоруською] Я ось приїхав і вивчив українську мову,
і розмовляю українською мовою.
[білоруською] І мені було дивно, що громадяни України
знаходять відмовки, щоб тільки не вчити її.
[білоруською] Під час протестів люди
раптом зрозуміли, що вони білоруси
[білоруською] і багато попереходили на білоруську мову
або намагались розмовляти білоруською.
[білоруською] Багато дізнались раптом,
що білоруський, нормальний білоруський прапор –
[білоруською] біло-червоно-білий,
а не ось ця червоно-зелена х*рня.
[білоруською] І ці протести були міцним імпульсом
для багатьох, щоб відчути себе частиною білоруської культури.
[білоруською] Багато в Україні просто не знають,
скажімо так, історію протестів у Білорусі.
[білоруською] І чомусь я зустрічав таке, мовляв:
«А чому ви 20 років мовчали?»
[білоруською] По-перше, протести відбулися
1995 року, великі протести.
[білоруською] З перевертанням ментівських
машин були весною 1996-го.
[білоруською] Потім 1997 року були великі протести,
1999-го. Дуже часто.
[білоруською] Протести були, але чим вони відрізнялися,
[білоруською] що до 2020 року виходила
все ж таки відносно невелика кількість людей.
[білоруською] Меншість.
[білоруською] А 2020 року люди обурились,
що їх обдурили з підрахунком голосів.
[білоруською] І ось з 2020 року, можна сказати, більша частина
білорусів не задоволена так званою владою, незаконною.
[білоруською] Велика ілюзія,
що щось може допомогти країні з-за кордону.
[білоруською] І загалом усі, хто перебуває в Білорусі,
розуміють, що не треба сподіватись на умовний Захід.
[білоруською] І те, що він допомагає: та ж Литва
допомагає дуже міцно, Польща допомагає.
[білоруською] Але все одно головне –
[білоруською]  зміни в країні зроблять люди,
які перебувають усередині країни.
[білоруською] З еміграції ти не скинеш,
не зміниш владу.
[білоруською] Ситуація зміниться тільки тоді,
[білоруською] коли всередині самої країни буде
критична кількість людей, налаштованих на зміни.
[білоруською] Напевно, білорусам з українцями
простіше порозумітись, ніж з будь-ким іншим.
[білоруською] Знову ж таки тому, що в нас
подібні культурні коди, подібна історія, подібні мови.
[білоруською] Ми розуміємо одне одного.
[білоруською] І у нас є спільний ворог,
проти якого ми боремось.
[білоруською] І в цій боротьбі ми, звісно, один
одному і одна одній могли би бути корисними.
[білоруською] В України й Білорусі,
мені здається, близькі шляхи в майбутнє.
[білоруською] І нам важливо триматись один одного.
[білоруською] Тим часом замість миру з військових складів
завезли страх у широкому асортименті.
[білоруською] Смердючий, слизький,
навіть продавчині гидують брати його в руки.
[білоруською] Але кому він тепер потрібен.
[білоруською] Маємо шикарні солодощі любові,
варення адреналіну,
[білоруською] самої злості і великий торт перемоги,
що доспіває неспішно в мільйонах сердець.